Speaker 1: Let's talk about the much anticipated
debate last night between the current Republican
Georgia governor, Brian Kemp, and the Democratic
challenger, Stacey Abrams. Stacey Abrams is
genuinely brilliant. She's really good at
debates. She actually knows things about so
many different issues. And it came through in
the debate. But Brian Kemp just couldn't resist
doing the angry black woman routine. Check
out what he had to say. This is really like
a good old boy. Tired debate strategy. The black
woman is upset and she's mad and she's angry.
Speaker 3: I know Ms.. Abrams is upset and mad.
Speaker 1: And that knowing tilt of the head from
Stacey Abrams. Now, I have to tell you, she was no
more mad than anybody else on the stage. In fact,
the libertarian guy was furious that they wouldn't
take his ideas seriously because they're crazy
ideas or let him speak as much as he wanted to.
And we're going to get to that in a moment. But
this entire you're mad and upset. She was no
more mad and upset than anybody else. And it
was just another one of these pathetic, racially
based tropes. Now, she did really, really well
at one point when she was asked
something along the rights. Along
the lines of what's the biggest danger
facing Georgia? She said, the biggest
danger is the guy who's currently the governor.
Speaker 2: This is a governor who's for the last
four years has beat his chest but delivered very
little for most Georgians. He has weakened gun
laws and flooded our streets. He has weakened
our privacy rights and our women's rights. He
has denied women the access to reproductive
care. The most dangerous thing facing Georgia
is four more years of Brian Kemp. We need a
governor who actually understands the math
and the morality. This is a governor.
Speaker 1: Who she I mean, listen,
it's very common right now that candidates don't
know anything. Like when you ask Mehmet Oz, hey,
can you, like, talk about health care policy and
how you would bridge the gap between A and B and
what do you think is the best way to get care
but to give you know, he'll just go with one of
those weird rants like the one he did about,
you know, send people to like a medical tent
and just give them like a five minute exam or
some like he doesn't really understand things
at a policy level. There's a total lack of
empathy. There's a total lack of lack of
pragmatism as to how you actually get bills passed
and and get money for the things you need to do.
Stacey Abrams knows so much like she is head and
shoulders above so many of the people that are
running right now. And she's stuck in this insane
situation with a lot of cuckoo Georgia voters,
many totally sensible Georgia voters as well, and
a governor who goes, oh, she's angry, she's mad
and she's angry and she really knows about so many
different things. Here's another clip where Brian
Kemp oh, by the way, this is another theme in a
lot of the debates that we've been covering and
we've covered now must be about ten or so just
in the last few weeks. The Republican will just
lie about what the lies or lie about their record.
They'll just completely make it up. Brian Kemp did
a lot of that last night where he said, listen,
we have a full background check law for firearms
purchases in Georgia. Every single purchase
requires a background check. And of course,
that's not true. There is the private sale
loophole. There is the gun show loophole.
And Stacey Abrams can do nothing to prevent
herself from interrupting. Understandably so,
because Kemp just can't stop lying or won't on.
Speaker 3: Well, there is a 32nd background
check. There is a federal background check
on every individual that buys a firearm in
the United States that shouldn't exist either.
That is not. Well, that's the point. It's not
true. I understand the point you're making.
But the point is, when you buy a firearm,
you get a background check.
Speaker 2: Mr..
Speaker 3: KELLY None of the laws were changed.
Speaker 2: Mr. KEMP If you purchased a weapon
in Georgia through a gun sale
or a private sale. I hope you're
all right. We're going to have to move.
Speaker 1: Yeah, she's completely correct.
Of course. This this is the widely known gun
show loophole, private sale, you know, family,
family sale loophole. And the libertarian guy in
the middle who is trying to talk over everybody,
he says we shouldn't have any background checks
whatsoever. I guess. I mean, he by the way,
the libertarian during yesterday's debate said
a get rid of gun safety regulations, get rid of
fiat money, get rid of public education. I can't
even remember the full list of what he said then.
He was furious. No one was taking him seriously.
So Kelly. Stacey Abrams doing everything she could
here to try to inject some truth and reality
into the conversation. One other moment that
I will play for. Were you a moment about a plans
where Brian Kemp took this sort of this is kind
of like a an escape hatch to any issue. You don't
really want to deal with this to say let's study
that issue. Stacey Abrams was having none of it
when it came to helping minority owned businesses.
Speaker 3: A lot of Georgians, including
African-Americans and other minorities, cannot go
to work if their kids are not in the classroom. We
have the lowest unemployment rate in the country
for African-Americans. We also were named the
top. We're in the top ten of the states for
black entrepreneurship in the state of Georgia. So
our economy is incredible and we will continue to
work with all of those entrepreneurs in the days
ahead and working class Georgians, because we are
the ones that have been fighting for you. When
Ms.. Abrams was not, we were giving tax refunds.
We were doing tax cuts. We were suspending
the gas tax to help you deal with 40 year
high inflation. When she was criticizing Stacey.
Speaker 2: Abrams 32nd rebuttal, I would point
out that Mr. Kemp did not address the needs of
purchasing and contracts for black and Brown owned
businesses, which is what he has refused to do for
the last 16 years. We know that $10.9 billion has
been delivered to the state of Georgia through two
recent acts at the congressional level. And Brian
Kemp does not have a plan for making certain that
people of color have access to those contracts,
access to purchasing. It was only in July of this
year that he finally acknowledged that there might
be a problem. He said that we need to study it.
I would tell him, just cheat off of my paper. I
know the answer. We need a governor who actually
believes in equity, racial equity, economic equity
in the state of Georgia. And I will deliver.
Speaker 1: So, listen, here's the bottom line with
this race, unfortunately. Stacey Abrams I keep
mistaking Kemp and saying Kelly Abrams Which is
not what I mean to say. Stacey Abrams is falling
further and further behind Brian Kemp. And much of
this is happening. I believe, because there have
actually not been really clear statements made
about what is at stake if these Republicans win
in November. Now, Stacey Abrams has made it clear,
but the bigger picture, we have to zoom out and
really think about all of these races. And this
applies in Pennsylvania. This applies in Florida,
Arizona, Georgia, really everywhere. You know,
we can have substantive policy debates about
what should the level of taxation be or as
far as states go, property taxes or some of
these other policy things. There is a movement
nationwide right now from the Republican Party
wherein their focus is how can we just take more
and more control of all of the basic systems
on which we depend? Voting, infrastructure,
education, torpedo some of them deliberately in
order to reinforce our control. It's insanely
authoritarian. And that big picture, I don't
think is being effectively enough communicated
to voters now that that's sort of a bigger rant
in terms of the numbers. Stacey Abrams Five and a
half points behind Brian Kemp On average right
now, it's it's not out of reach necessarily.
But let's be honest that two and a half
weeks to make up five and a half points
in a gubernatorial race and a sort of
reddish leaning state, which sometimes
votes for a Democratic president and right now
has two Democratic senators, I should mention,
is a is something that has to be overcome.
Now, one last thought on last night's debate,
there was this libertarian guy who was also
part of the debate. And on the one hand,
I have mixed feelings as to what position I should
take on this, because on the one hand, I want
third parties. I hate the two party duopoly. We
need more voices at debates. If you qualify for
the debate, you should be there and get as much
time to speak as everybody else. At the same time,
we know the guy has no shot. He was a
complete lunatic, anti-vax, anti-everything,
and he's not going to be the next governor. So
there was also time wasted from really forcing
Brian Kemp to have to engage with Stacey Abrams on
the issues. And so I have sort of mixed feelings
about the participation of the libertarian guy.
But needless to say, Stacey Abrams, super smart,
did an incredibly good job. Will it make
a difference? We'll have to wait and see.